the crusade to inject every single
person in the country with the covid
vacs regardless of their age health or
risk of dying from the woofloo has
suffered a setback as two young children
in indiana suffer from heart problems
after a pharmacist accidentally injected
them with the pfizer covid vaccine
instead of their flu shot
family with children four and five years
old say they were accidentally given
full adult doses of the pfizer
coronavirus vaccine
instead of flu shots they say it
happened on october 4th at the walgreens
on st joseph avenue the family of four
includes two adults and two young
children both too young for the pfizer
or any other covid vaccine well the
family's attorney daniel thule shared
with us what he says are vaccination
cards given to the family by walgreens
they show children born in 2016 and 2017
were given a pfizer coronavirus vaccine
the family says they left the pharmacy
thinking they had gotten their flu shots
but a walgreens employee later called
them and said they had made a mistake
thule says the children have been taken
to a pediatric cardiologist and the
family was told both are showing signs
of heart issues we've reached out to
walgreens several times but have not yet
heard back
meanwhile several nordic countries are
pausing one of the vaccines for young
people as more and more reports of heart
problems crop up but the ruling class
doesn't want us talking about any of
those scientific realities a lot to
cover
if the powers that be do not censor this
show i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from am who says
school shooter is out on bail after
shooting four people but there were
people languishing in jail for months
for trespassing and disorderly conduct
at most at the capitol yes this is true
school shooters if they don't
fit the democrats racial and ideological
narrative they they didn't do anything
wrong they're fine they need to it's
actually a matter of justice that they
get out on bail but the
insurrectionists the worst coup d'etat
those people are gonna rot it's not a
hypocrisy it's just
it's just the hierarchy today it's just
the way that that our society operates
and the the more we deny that the worse
off we're going to be you know we need
to take care of ourselves we've got to
take care of our bodies we've got to
take care of our fellow americans we've
got to take care of the american rancher
we can do it all at the same time with
good ranchers when was the last time you
think you had american meat well you you
probably think you just had it you go to
the grocery store you just assume you're
getting american meat sometimes it says
local meat yeah it's local to latin
america it's local from far away did you
know that over 80 percent of the
grass-fed beef sold in the united states
is imported from other countries from
overseas very often well
goodranchers.com has made it safe
convenient easy and delicious to get
your favorite meat top quality meat
to help out the american farmer and
rancher goodranchers.com delivers
american craft beef and better than
organic chicken they've got t-bones
fillets strips gourmet burgers i
especially i love all their stuff but
the burgers oh my gosh they're so juicy
and delicious you get steakhouse quality
at a price that every family can afford
go to goodranchers.com
knowles right now save 20 bucks or
better yet subscribe and save on each
box of mouth-watering american meats
that will show up on schedule right to
your door that is twenty dollars off and
free express shipping if you go to
goodranchers.com knowles or use code
knowles at checkout 20 bucks off free
express shipping at goodranchers.com
knowles
so much to get to on this columbus day
happy columbus day everybody we'll get
to christopher columbus a little bit
later one of my favorite holidays of the
year
before that though before we speak of
the italian people sailing with the
spaniards we need this talk of the
nordic people who are right now pausing
their their vaccines so right now sweden
the sweden health ministry announced
last wednesday that it's going to pause
injections of moderna for people aged 30
and younger so it's actually pretty high
we talk about young people we're going
all the way up to 30 because of risk of
heart problems denmark has a similar
pause for people aged 18 and younger
that according to bloomberg
finland the following day issued the
same kind of pause the finnish health
official mika salminen
says that the government's going to
pause the injections
of of the modern vaccine in people also
age 30
and younger
the reason is myocarditis which even the
cdc and the fda acknowledge is a risk
with these vaccines
and specifically in young people a
nordic study involving finland sweden
norway and denmark found that men under
the age of 30 who received the modernist
spike vaxx had at a slightly higher risk
than others of developing myocarditis
how slight that risk is
is apparently up for debate
uh now the left does not want us to have
that debate uh the left wants us to
pretend that the vaccines are 100
absolutely effective 100
absolutely safe for every single person
don't raise any questions but of course
we know that no matter how safe a
vaccine is there's always going to be
some risk and the people who are denying
that risk are are destroying their own
credibility one friend of mine who who
did permit this debate is my friend alex
michelson he
hosts the show the issue is on fox la
and he invited me on with a left winger
named brian tyler cohen and we debated
the vaccine mandate issue last friday i
really enjoyed it i really liked
speaking to both of those gentlemen i
thought it was a productive respectful
debate so you can watch that debate
maybe we'll post a link of it somewhere
but it's me and brian tyler cohen on the
issue is and i think we think we both
lay out the case a bet as well as we can
for our respective sides and i think
that the side against the mandates is
the winning side because obviously there
are legitimate reasons not to get this
vaccine okay there was a study came out
of uc davis not that long ago the study
showed that young men some young men
face greater risk from the vaccine than
they do of dying from the coronavirus
okay and it's that's just the science
and that's just the study and that's
just the experts and i know the left
doesn't want us to talk about those
scientists and experts but there it is
it's a real it's a real study that came
out furthermore we know that the the
vaccines in in rare cases perhaps but
nevertheless have caused blood clotting
in women even killed a woman and that's
why they paused the johnson and johnson
vaccine we know it can cause nerve
damage as can other vaccines
we know this the cdc and the fda have
acknowledged this and then furthermore
there is the religious objection because
all of the vaccines were at the very
least developed if not also produced by
using fetal stem cells so there are
there are obviously reasons that people
might not want to get the the vaccine to
say nothing of the fact that the
infection fatality rate is half a
percent
for people 65 and under
and for kids for young people the the
survival rate is
99.997 and for teenagers for most
teenagers it's 99.99 so it just seems to
me there are legit reasons to avoid
getting this vaccine and the left
doesn't want us talking about it and
then when these
rare events come up like heart
inflammation in a bunch of people then
they've got to pause the vaccine and it
further further squanders their
credibility and by the way
even
as recently as last december joe biden
himself said he did not support mass
mandates do you forget that
no i don't think it should be mandatory
i wouldn't demand to be mandatory but i
would do everything in my power just
like i don't think masks have to be made
mandatory nationwide i'll do everything
in my power as
a president united states to encourage
people to do the right thing and when
they do it demonstrate to the matter so
i misspoke and i said he didn't oppose
he didn't support mask mandates he also
didn't support mass mandates but in
addition what he's speaking there at the
top about is vaccine mandates and he
opposed both of those things and now he
supports both of those things and it
further tarnishes these people's
credibility but beyond the kovid stuff
for a second i've got to talk about
a far worse proclamation that that joe
biden made
far worse than anything involving the
virus and the wu flu and the masks and
the shots i'm talking about joe biden's
historic first ever white house
proclamation
on indigenous people's day
indigenous people's day is the lib
alternative to columbus day because in
the lib telling christopher columbus one
of the greatest men in history the man
who discovered the new world without
whom we would not be here right now he
was an evil terrible monster and
genocidal and
they make a bunch of claims that simply
aren't true they base them on the
dubious historical documents of a man
named francisco de bobadia who was
columbus's chief political rival it
would be like basing a history of donald
trump
on hillary clinton's writings or vice
versa history of hillary clinton on
donald trump it's just preposterous
actually the far more credible accounts
are that that columbus while
a broken man as we all are was actually
relatively quite a lot kinder to the
natives than
than the other spaniards were and
furthermore that he was an intrepid
explorer a man of of devout catholic
faith and one of the greatest men of his
age and of any age for that matter so
now we're not allowed to celebrate
columbus we have to celebrate indigenous
peoples day my only question is
which indigenous peoples are we
celebrating
are we celebrating
the taino indians that was the first
amiable tribe that that columbus
encountered when he arrived at san
salvador
or are we talking about the carob
islanders the carob islanders or the
people who attacked the taino indians
columbus noticed that the tainos had
scars on their bodies and they got them
from the carobs
from whom we get the word cannibal they
were a savage group of of native indians
in the caribbean they ate people and
they bred babies at which they
considered in the words of samuel
elliott morris and a pulitzer
prize-winning harvard historian
they considered babies to be a
particularly tooth-some morsel so are we
celebrating the baby eating carob
cannibals what about the aztecs perhaps
the oh those much-feted aztecs you know
that wonderful civilization that we read
about destroyed by the awful spanish
conquistadors the aztecs who at the
consecration of their temple at
tenochtitlan murdered um oh yes 80 000
people over the course of four days by
ripping their still beating hearts out
of their chest and then kicking their
bodies down the pyramid does that is
does that sound like the kind of
indigenous people we're supposed to
celebrate what about the iroquois
perhaps the iroquois would be a good
example of this the iroquois who who uh
also ripped out the still beating heart
of their victims one of them was a
catholic saint by the way and uh ate
them alive they get engaged in ritual
cannibalism are we which which
indigenous peoples are we celebrating
today now you might say michael michael
it's not fair
to judge the indigenous peoples or any
people for that matter by the worst
things that they did and exclusively by
the worst things that they did oh is
that so
oh is that so i guess that's a fair
point so perhaps we ought to apply that
standard to columbus because if you
apply this standard of only judging
people by the very worst things that
they did first of all most of the things
that people accuse columbus of doing he
didn't even do as carol delaney
preeminent
columbus historian points out they
accuse him of doing things that actually
other people did that very often he
himself opposed but but even beyond that
let's let's say that he actually did the
things they accused him of which he
didn't
when you compare him to
the aztecs and the iroquois and the
carobs he looks like a saint far from a
sinner he looks he looks like one of the
greatest men in history and so if we're
going to celebrate the indigenous people
certainly much much more so we ought to
celebrate columbus day and i encourage
you to do just that we gotta stay safe
here folks we gotta protect our
civilization and our homes and ourselves
which is why i would recommend you check
out
ring help me help you help me give you
peace of mind with ring
you all know about ring i've been
telling you about it for years ring
allows you to see and speak to whoever
is outside your door whether you're in
the house whether you're at the office
whether you're on a beach on the other
side of the world
you can do it all from a simple app well
it's not just your your front door you
can keep an eye on every inch of your
home indoors and outdoors all from that
wonderful app with ring alarm it's super
easy to install it's extremely
inexpensive it's just amazing amazing
technology and i have a lot of peace of
mind all right when i go on the road
which is a fair bit i love knowing that
my beautiful wife and cute little baby
can know who is outside the door before
they open up that door just give
yourself peace of mind protect your home
anytime from anywhere with ring alarm go
to ring.com knowles canon wles for a
special offer on a ring alarm security
kit today build a system that's right
for your home have it up and running in
minutes even you can install it even i
can install it ring dot com slash
knowles canon wlas that's ring.com
knowles
speaking of the hispanic people
you know without christopher columbus
there would be no such thing as
hispanics
there would what is an hispanic person
or a latino person
it's someone who descends from the
native indigenous americans
and the spaniards
and that mixture of peoples came
together because of christopher columbus
so if you like a latino if you are a
latino if you appreciate
the hispanic people
you ought to thank christopher columbus
because without him they would not exist
well speaking of the hispanic people
president
joe biden is now
canceling all remaining
contracts border wall contracts that
would
try to secure our southern border
and the left typically tries to present
the illegal immigration crisis as a just
a question of racism against hispanics
mind you
hispanic people who came to this country
legally are not exactly the biggest
supporters of illegal immigration far
from it and the polls reflect that
but joe biden is he is now even knocking
down the pretense that he cares at all
about the immigration crisis the the
last
stop against this sort of thing the last
physical representation of a way to
prevent this crisis the border wall joe
biden is ending he's can't quote
cancelling the remaining border wall
carrier contracts located within u.s
border patrol's laredo sector and all
border barrier contracts located in the
rio grande valley sector so i just what
i don't want to hear anymore
is from the squish republicans who say
joe biden's incompetence has led to a
crisis at the border
it's not he biden is somewhat
incompetent on a number of of issues but
what's happening at the border is not
because of democrat incompetence it is
by democrat design they want the border
open they want millions of illegal
aliens foreign nationals to pour into
this country they think it will give
them a permanent electoral majority and
so they're going to do it and they don't
particularly care for the american
nation so they hate the symbol of the
american nation and the demarcator of
the american nation which is the border
they don't want there to be a border
because they don't really want there to
be an america and
if you can come up with some other
explanation to me as to why at a time of
unprecedented illegal immigration joe
biden would cancel the remaining border
wall contracts please i'm all ears give
me the alternative explanation but to me
it seems pretty clear just as it has for
a long time but this is i think
indisputable
that the democrats do not want there to
be any sort of border to the south they
want to flood the country with foreign
nationals and they're going to entice
foreign nationals to enter this country
illegally you're seeing this in the
three and a half trillion dollar
budget bill
and i hesitate even to call it a three
and a half trillion dollar bill it's not
it's actually more likely a five and a
half trillion dollar bill
even the new york times by the way is
admitting that it's going to cost more
than three and a half trillion dollars
so this bill includes a whole lot of
terrible stuff
but
one of the more offensive aspects of it
is that the bill
promises free community college
for illegal aliens
which which is offensive
on two fronts
one because
americans
ordinary americans who follow the law
who just
pay their taxes
they
have to pay for their kid to go to
college in most cases right they they
work hard they pay for their kid to go
to college they're paying taxes even if
they already get some tuition assistance
at a community college they're still
paying taxes for that
and illegal aliens who flout our laws
who break our laws
they get to go on the american taxpayers
dime that seems wrong that seems unjust
but even beyond that
you you now have a system where we are
creating even more incentives for people
to come across that border
which is not particularly nice for the
the even the illegal aliens themselves
they're just sort of pawns here and
they've got to pay vicious coyotes and
there's a lot of rape and sexual assault
along the journey and a lot of crime and
a lot of very bad stuff goes on but
people are so desperate to get into
america they're willing to do it
and it creates this incentive
furthermore to erode the rule of law
here and
the cherry on top of that is that the
left gets more people into their
indoctrination centers which is why they
want to expand school used to be you'd
go first grade to 12th grade then it was
now everyone goes to kindergarten now
it's everyone goes to pre-k now it's
everyone goes to college and they just
want to keep
students in that state indoctrination
system for as long as possible even if
it's illegal aliens because that will
help them craft the future country
what is a country what is a country if
foreign nationals
are tr are entitled to all the same
goodies
as citizens
then then there is no such thing as a
citizen
then there is no such thing as a country
then it's just a big space and it's a
free-for-all and anyone can do what they
want
if you if you want to have a country
then you need to have something that
distinguishes your place
from other people's place and your
people from other people's people okay
and if you don't if nothing
borders if rights if the ability to go
to certain schools if the ability to
vote even in some cases illegal aliens
can vote if that doesn't distinguish the
citizen from the non-citizen then there
is nothing that distinguishes them and
this is what the left has pushed for for
a long time and the new york times is
even admitting this now so
i pointed out
years ago now at this point that the
protests of the american flag
are not just some
[Music]
eccentric activity by the left to
protest police brutality or whatever i
said the flag is a symbol of the country
so if you're protesting the flag if
you're kneeling for the star spangled
banner for instance or if you are
desecrating the flag then you are
protesting the entire country which is
an incoherent action by the way if
you're going to rely on your first
amendment rights to
attack the country without which the
first amendment rights wouldn't exist
that is an incoherent action it doesn't
doesn't make a lot of sense and it's a
really serious problem and a lot of the
squishes said oh who cares oh michael
stop being such a culture warrior oh
stop being so worried it doesn't matter
they protest the flag it's no big deal
well if you protest the flag long enough
then it's going to be quite clear you're
protesting the country
and the new york times is admitting this
the new york times says
a fourth of july symbol of unity that
may
no longer unite
so the new york times writes today
flying the american flag from the back
of a pickup truck or over a lawn is
increasingly seen as a clue albeit an
imperfect one to a person's political
affiliation in a deeply divided nation
right that's true when we used to say
when we used to say that
the the
right is patriotic and the libs hate the
country we were told that's not true
dissent is patriotic we're the most
patriotic people in the world now
they're kind of admitting this they say
no if you fly an american flag you're
probably a republican
and
by the way if you fly a rainbow flag or
a black lives matter flag that means
you're probably a dem because
because the the libs don't like the
american nation so increasingly
conservatives and republicans are
defenders of the american nation and the
libs are defenders of call it liberal
empire you know the rainbow flag is a
symbol of empire and a specifically
liberal empire that makes universal
claims about sex and identity and that
are just as true in timbuktu as they are
in the united states it transcends
national boundaries which is what the
left wants to do
they're now suggesting uh at the new
york times that we have a new flag they
want a new flag because they want a new
country and if you want to keep your
country then you got to fight back
against this stuff at the level of
symbolism and at the level of raw
political
power and speaking of the new york times
i
i can't let this go the you know begging
for a new american flag is far from the
least most ridiculous thing that was in
their paper over the past few days
the most ridiculous thing you might have
seen in the new york times
was their epic
correction
i'm just going to give you without any
context on the the article that's being
corrected here is the new york times's
correction
usually in corrections what are sorry we
said the number was 15 instead of 14.
sorry we misspelled the name of the
person we were writing about it has one
little line of correction here's this
new york times correction an earlier
version of this article incorrectly
described actions taken by regulators in
sweden and denmark they've halted use of
the modern vaccine in children they have
not begun offering single doses the
article also misstated the number of
coveted hospitalizations in u.s children
it is more than 63 000 from august 2020
to october 21
not
900 000 since the beginning of the
pandemic in addition the article
misstated the timing of an fda meeting
on authorization of the pfizer biotech
vaccine for children it is later this
month not next week
but other than that the article was
totally right did
did the article get anything right
because the correction was about the
length of an article so typical uh
attention to detail
and fact and reality from the new york
times
and the sad thing is we'll make fun of
this correction on the show
a lot of conservatives will notice this
correction and no one else will they run
the article on page
a1 i don't know exactly where this
particular article ran but they they run
the wild sensational left-wing claims
toward the front of the paper and they
issue the correction days and days and
days later sometimes in print sometimes
just online and you barely see it so
they get away with the story
no credibility whatsoever and
when we catch it you got it you got to
remember to apply that to other stories
if they were dead wrong about that what
else are they dead wrong about
you know
christopher columbus i don't know if
i've mentioned this to you yet
christopher columbus was a great man one
of the greatest men in history
and the left is peddling a lot of
anti-history
to smear his name so we're going to
celebrate him columbus unlocked the
greatest continent our wonderful
continent and we're letting you unlock
the greatest content
see what we did there for 35 off today
only head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe enter code columbus to get 35
off celebrate this terrific guy who made
this great continent and content
possible also tomorrow tuesday october
12th we are taking backstage to an
entirely new level instead of the usual
daily wire studio we're gonna be live
streaming our conversation on stage at
the famous ryman auditorium right here
in nashville doing what we do best
making sense that's what we do is that
what we do best
this will be an event in a live stream
unlike any other we've ever done we're
thrilled to be able to share with all of
you we've got a lot of exciting
announcements
some of which you are certainly not
going to want to miss so be sure to tune
in join me ben shapiro candace owens
jeremy bourne matt walsh andrew clavin
and our live audience for a backstage
like never before tomorrow's live stream
will begin at 8 30 eastern 7 30 central
head on over to dailywire.com or the
daily wire youtube channel to catch the
show we'll be right back with a lot more
we got some good news which is a rarity
these days in our news cycle but some
good news on this columbus day
texas pro-life law the six-week abortion
ban is back in effect now you might say
michael i didn't know it ever went out
of effect yes it did go out of effect
because the law passes in texas and the
law is a sort of unique pro-life law
that's why it didn't just get smacked
down right away the law does not
just outright ban abortion they're not
able to do that because of the
ridiculous roe vs wade and planned
parenthood v casey decisions because
those decisions created a fictitious
constitutional right to abortion the
laws in texas and other states can't
just outright ban abortion so what they
did was they permitted
citizens of the state maybe citizens of
other states too to sue people who
participate in an abortion not the
mother but but people who drive you
there people who perform the abortions
anyone who's associated with the
abortion and so that for all intents and
purposes shuts down abortion so some
degenerate judge
who wanted to legislate from the bench
said no absolutely not we're going to
stop this law from taking effect well
now another federal judge
has come in
and
lifted the injunction against the
enforcement of the near total abortion
ban that was from the fifth circuit
court of appeals
uh judge robert pittman had issued the
injunction blocking the law and now that
has been lifted so
babies are going to be saved at least
for now in texas the reason i even bring
up this story i'm sure this is going to
be reversed 10 million more times before
they they settle the question the reason
i bring it up is to remind you
it's not enough just to pass the law
if we really lived under the schoolhouse
rock kind of government i'm a bill up on
capitol hill that sort of thing then it
might be enough you pass the law and
then it's good then you're all good and
you can
okay go home we're all happy but that's
not how our government really works
yes you got to pass the pro-life law
then you have to enforce it then you got
to fight it in the courts and then you
got to keep on fighting tooth and nail
we're going to be fighting this thing
for years
for years to try to defend pro-life the
passage of a law like this is not the
end it's only the beginning and you've
got to gear up for years and years and
years long battle that's what the left
has done is why they gained a lot of
ground on abortion and uh if we want to
get that ground back we're gonna have to
fight for a long time
as well because these are very sick
people these are very very sick people
who are defending abortion i read an
interview
from the lily i think this is put out by
what is it from the washington post i
think
it was an interview
of a texas abortionist here's the
headline
abortion care is a calling for this
texas doctor now he faces a dilemma
risk lawsuits or quit i looked into this
this guy
he
he said that that killing babies is his
quote life's calling he says if i can
keep doing this for the rest of my
career i will be very
happy
he has kids he's a deadbeat so he
doesn't it's not like he sees his kids
all that much
he left his family or his family left
him and he didn't try to get them back
he's got these three kids but his
ex-wife
says that even when they he lived near
the kids he didn't see them very much
quote he was so involved in his career
then residency then he found his love of
abortion care so even when he lived
right down the road he didn't see his
kids very much because he was too
obsessed with killing other people's
babies
now he's married to a second wife
who is a big lib she was voted most
likely to start a protest by her grad
school peers
they refer to each other as partners
like they're either homosexuals or
members of an accounting firm but they
don't refer to one another as their
husband and wife right my husband my
wife no that's far too traditional and
actually speaking of unusual sexual
desires he refers to himself as a queer
even though he's got a wife but he
refers to himself as queer and quote a
little femi
uh so he's confused he's confused
there's a lot of confusion going on here
and he spends his life uh killing other
people's babies and he makes a lot of
money doing it you know he's got student
debt he's got to pay child support
and so he makes money every time he
kills a baby he makes money for it so
obviously he wants to keep the business
going keep the racket going and the
reason i mention this guy's one just
i'm actually sort of shocked that a
left-wing outlet would give you a peek
into these kinds of people because you
just look at this guy and he looks like
a creep and he is a creep and he's a
ghoul but
the other reason i bring it up is
that guy
this doctor is the logical conclusion of
safe legal and rare
right
safe legal and rare was the old
democratic line on abortion which is
they wanted they defended killing babies
on mass million a year but they didn't
they understood that that was an evil
thing so they didn't want to take total
ownership of it so they say look
for whatever reason it has to be legal
but it should be rare it's not like i
support abortion i just support the
right to choose well that never made
sense because if abortion is morally
similar to murder then it shouldn't be
legal and if it's not if it's just like
getting your appendix out then there's
no reason for it to be rare and the
moment you start defending the right
quote unquote the right to an abortion
eventually you have to defend its
substantive goodness as well and that's
what the left is doing now he's saying
it's his life's calling he just he loves
it he is bloodlust knows no end and so
this guy might be a particular
psychopath but anyone who is going to
defend abortion
ultimately has to partake of this kind
of
argument and and to see it unvarnished
to just look at the disorder of this
thing right in the eyes
i i think tells you what side you ought
to be on do you want to be on the side
of this psycho or do you want to be on
the side of
the babies of protecting the little
innocent
babies speaking of the sexual revolution
got to defend my buddy charlie kirk for
a moment charlie kirk as he often does
was trending on twitter he got in
trouble charlie is always getting
himself in trouble and medium matters
and jason campbell who i refer to as my
personal publicist he is one of the
people who we're at media matters they
work they just watch all of our shows
all day and they try to get us fired and
they haven't they've gotten close
sometimes but they have not succeeded in
doing that so he was going after charlie
and he pulled this clip from charlie
said this is shocking this is insane
he says quote charlie kirk warns that
democrats want you living in sexual
anarchy here's what charlie said you
think we're still living in the 1980s
where the democrats actually want
what's best for america
the democrats want to destroy the
country we know this
this is not new stuff
it's not profound thinking
they want to see america completely
obliterated the constitution shredded
and remade in their own
san francisco brooklyn malibu manhattan
image
where there is no cultural identity
where you live in sexual anarchy
for private property is a thing of the
past
and the ruling class controls everything
we know this crazy that charlie can you
believe charlie said that's insane i
totally disagree but wow what
but what did he get wrong exactly what
what part of what he just said
was wrong
i think a conservative will listen to
that and say no that's obviously just
common sense but what's weird here is
that
i think even a liberal even some left
winger like the people at media matters
if they're being honest which they
usually are not but if they're being
honest at least with themselves
i think they would agree with what
charlie said too
what is sexual anarchy
it seems to me that the the dominant
view of sexual morality since the 1960s
at least
is
if it feels good do it
if you want to do something sexually if
you want to have pre-marital sex if you
want to hook up if you want to do
whatever you want to do
if if you want to do it you should do it
and there's only one little caveat here
which is that everything's got to be
consensual so if things are not
consensual then eventually you get some
me too problems and things they're not
going to go that far as to defend rape
but anything short of non-consensual sex
it seems to me the left defends
right that well what is sexual anarchy
sexual anarchy right anarchy is the
system where there's no formal
government you don't really have to
follow any any rules beyond the defense
of one's own radical individual autonomy
and consent
and then you apply this in the realm of
sex it seems like charlie is using a
very precise term to describe exactly
what the left wants but the left knows
that that's insane at some
deep deep down level i think the left
knows that that is insane to say that
sexually or in any other aspect of life
you can do absolutely whatever you want
and there are no rules and no moral
order whatsoever so they don't want to
admit that but that is what they're
saying and that is what they're
defending and charlie kirk was
absolutely 100
correct
speaking of consent
you might have some trouble getting back
from a vacation getting to a business
trip even getting here to to nashville
for our backstage show tomorrow i got a
very sad message i got an instagram from
someone
who was unpacking her bag because she
had booked a flight to come to
nashville for the backstage show she
bought her ticket but she couldn't come
because
a lot of airlines notably southwest
airlines
is canceling a ton of flights just
yesterday
southwest cancelled more than a thousand
flights a thousand flights 25
more than 25 of all the flights they had
that day
now the airline hasn't explained why
they canceled the flights they tried to
kind of blame it on weather
but i don't think it was weather
i'm skeptical that it was weather
i suspect
they're trying quote to recover our
operation because of a reported and
rumored employee sick out
that employees not just of of southwest
but of
a lot of other airlines
are protesting the vaccine mandate
because
while one may might make the prudential
judgment to get the vaccine right they
might say oh my risk from the vaccine is
not so great and my risk from the virus
might be a little high so okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna take the risk i'm gonna get
the vaccine and plenty of people have
done that and ostensibly they seem like
they're completely fine but other
employees might say you know
i'm healthy i'm young
there is some risk of the vaccine i'm
not so afraid of my risk from the virus
so i'm not going to get it and you
southwest and you osha and you joe biden
are not going to make me get it
so they're protesting it and now the
flights are canceled and that's too bad
and i'm very sorry for people whose
flights are canceled and i travel all
the time by airplane and i bet some of
my flights are going to be canceled too
and that's going to be very inconvenient
but this is actually great news and the
great news is this the people still have
a lot of power
the people still have the ruling class
has taken a ton of political power a
disproportionate amount of political
power
that's true in big tech it's true in the
government it's true in corporations
it's true in the schools they they are
punching above their weight in terms of
their political power but the people
still have some power too
and if you just don't go along with this
stuff and you do so in a respectful
dignified moral way but you just don't
really go along with the overreaches of
these
of these predator
ruling class oligarchs
you're still going to have some power
and they're really going to get upset
when they're when their flights do not
show up on time you know speaking of the
people versus the ruling class i have to
mention this at least briefly
the economist just sort of just like the
neo-liberal establishment magazine the
economist
is trying to get us to eat bugs again
they j these guys really want us to eat
bugs i don't want to eat bugs but the
the neolibs the ruling class they really
want you see an article about this
every week it seems someone's trying to
say you know bugs are really good
oh bugs are a good source of protein we
you know
humans have historically shunned bugs
but we need to because bugs are
sustainable and it'll stop global
warming in the sun monster and so you
got to eat bugs and you know there's a
meme that has arisen in response to this
where people say i will not live in the
pod i will not eat the bugs i will not
consume your product or comply or go
along with this
why not why not is the question that the
economist and the ruling class asks why
won't you just eat the bugs why won't
you eat the bugs what what rational
argument are you i get you're freaked
out and creeped out by them but what's
the rational argument for not eating the
bugs
my argument is this
it's yucky it's yucky and it's
uncivilized and it's what savages do but
it's not what civilized people do and i
don't want to
and we all have this kind of wisdom of
repugnance that we just don't want to
eat the bugs we don't want to eat the
bugs and we don't have to eat the bugs
there is more to life than just matter
okay life is not just measured in the
grams of protein
in in any particular thing all right
there is culture there is civilization
there is a refinement there is a kind of
wisdom that that that defies the
rationalist utilitarian calculations
of our idiotic ruling class and and i
think we ought to trust that a lot more
and we still have the political right
to defend
it speaking of the gap between
the ruling class and the people
terry mcauliffe governor of virginia
running for reelection he's running
against the republican glenn younkin he
just got called out he just got smacked
down on a local news channel he was
asked about this nationwide phenomenon
of of parents showing up to their school
boards
parents of every color of every shape of
every stripe saying we do not want you
instructing our kids in critical race
theory and these kooky insane vicious
racial ideologies and gender ideologies
for that matter and we don't want that
in our schools
so
terry mcauliffe the governor of virginia
backed himself into a corner here
because he's got to
defend critical race theory and pretend
that it doesn't exist and the the anchor
on this show is not having it
so how do you define it anita it is not
taught here in virginia how do you
define it doesn't matter it's not taught
here in virginia so i'm not going to
speak
on what it is i'm not even spending my
time because the school board and
everyone else has come out and said it's
not talk it's racist
it's a dog whistle but if we don't have
a definition how can we say it's racist
i just want a definition from you
it's not taught here in virginia we can
ask about any topic here's what i've
said all along and it really bothers me
you know i re it really bothers me this
whole idea of stern parents up to create
the divisions our children are going
through such challenges today because of
kovid and we're talking about something
here today wasting
precious viewers time uh-huh keep
spinning buddy do you see the the two
arguments he's making simultaneously are
critical race theory does not exist here
and if you oppose it you're a racist
so hold on wait you i thought it doesn't
exist yeah but if you oppose the thing
that doesn't exist you're a big racist
huh and and the woman good honor i mean
she really holds his feet to the fire
she says i'm not asking you whether or
not it exists here i'm just asking you
but so we can have a conversation and so
we can ascertain whether or not it
exists
what is it because it doesn't it's not
here
yeah right but whether it's here or not
what is what is critical race theory and
he won't he won't give a definition and
it's not because he's a stupid man it's
because he knows that the moment he does
define critical race theory
it will become quite clear that it is
taught in these virginia schools
critical race theory a derivation of
critical theory a line of marxist
thinking that examines the culture
i've got here it is i've got the i've
got the definitive collection of
critical race theory essays here and it
is unless a a unified theory than it is
a gadfly on other systems but the short
version of it is that america is a white
supremacist place whiteness is evil
whiteness needs to be abolished even the
american system of capitalism is infused
and imbued with this whiteness and so
it's evil and wrong and we've got to
abolish it and completely up in the
culture that's basically what it is i
mean it makes other claims too but
that's what it is and that is being
taught in schools and in boardrooms and
all throughout
the culture and parents have every right
to oppose it
and
we ought to oppose that's where a lot of
this anti-columbus stuff comes from too
by the way it's just
anti-western culture right
columbus is in many ways an embodiment
of western civilization he's a self-made
man an intrepid explorer uh you know the
admiral of the ocean see deeply devoutly
catholic spread the gospel really great
guy and so people hate columbus for that
there was a tick tock that just just
went viral
i'm not on tick tock yet myself but i i
see them posted all around and so here
is a young
individual
of sort of androgynous
presentation uh going out and
and saying that if you defend columbus
you're evil you're racist you're stupid
and you're uneducated so he's going to
educate us
no matter what i say there's still going
to be that person that celebrates
columbus today
you trump supporters are all for donald
trump building this wall right you want
the immigrants banned so badly but let
me educate you illegal immigration
started with columbus and here are the
facts okay columbus came to their land
and he was not welcome there when he
arrived the indigenous this is this is
one
frustrating uh uh slogan from the left
they say you know amer americas had
immigrants from the very beginning
because all the the settlers who came
here were immigrants no they weren't
they were settlers they were conquerors
is what they were that's different
that's different than immigration i
understand there's some similarity here
but it's not that columbus applied to
the taino or carob
you know uh
border agency right he came and he
interacted somewhat peaceably with some
of them and then conquered others of
them and that's what happened that's
what the spaniards did very different
sort of thing and by the way indigenous
people conquer other indigenous people
though we talk about the lakota who who
had mount rushmore they had uh the black
hills and they always whine and complain
about how the americans took the land
from them their sacred wonderful land
well the lakota only had the black hills
starting in 1776 and they took it from
other native american tribes including
the cheyenne so do we give it back to
the lakota or do we give it back to the
cheyenne
the the native americans are people
right they are human beings and i think
we we diminish them when we pretend that
they're just some like pets or animals
or something living in this peaceable
harmony no they were men conquering
other men just like happens in the west
in the east and everywhere else and in
the case of columbus and the spaniards
the western civilization conquered their
native tribes and in many cases that was
a very good thing because those tribes
were up to a lot of bad stuff including
widespread human sacrifice and
cannibalism and and all other manner of
evil you know when arawak people of
native america they didn't kick him out
they didn't ban him they didn't build a
wall they didn't say he didn't belong
there they welcomed him with open arms
they shared their resources and culture
with him quite some of them were amiable
but
others murdered them to steal from them
you want to talk about looting during
black lives matter protests he was one
of the first looters not only did he
steal their land he stole their culture
and he forced his cultural practices on
them and he didn't steal their culture
he was never a hero he was always a
villain stop believing the lies he was
always so he's saying i guess the claim
here is that it's bad
it's bad to go in and cancel other
people's cultures right but
the left that makes this argument
wants to cancel the western culture and
take down our statues and take down our
heroes and take down the things that we
believe and including the statues of
christopher columbus but other people as
well
so
then it doesn't just become this
cultural relativistic argument it
becomes this idea that the indigenous
culture was really good and there were
some nice aspects of it they invented
cigars for instance and there were some
bad aspects of it like ritual
cannibalism and you know widespread
human slaughter and sacrifice so good
parts and bad parts but the argument
from the left is the indigenous culture
good western civilization greatest
civilization greatest culture ever in
the history of the world bad
and that argument is absolutely
preposterous it reminds me of a line
from tony soprano when his son
uh was reading howard zinn's left wing
crazy history and and his son started
speaking ill of columbus
i will bid you all a happy columbus day
and i will let tony soprano play us out
on michael knowles is the michael knoll
show
his history teacher mr cushman is
teaching your son that if columbus was
alive today he would go on trial for
crimes against humanity like milosevic
in you know europe
your teacher said that it's not just my
teacher it's the truth
it's in my history book
so you finally read the book and it's
bullsh tony
look he had to work at columbus shoes to
see what he went through
people thought the world was flat for
crying out loud
then he lived in an island with a bunch
of naked savages on it i mean it took a
lot of guts
you remember when we went to florida the
heat and those bugs well like it took
guts to murder people and put them in
chains he was a victim of his time who
cares it's what he did he discovered
america is what he did he was a brave
italian explorer and in this house
christopher columbus is a hero and a
story
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show